d'ailleurs on sait l est les capitales
je vais faire le jeu de mots et les
capitales la martinique avait pas de
raison que nous ne soyons pas justement
à fort de france aujourd'hui à
l'occasion du semi-marathon
international
nous tenons à faire notre retour au
moment où la haute saison touristique
dément pour nous il n'était pas autant
de positionner la yole grâce qui
pourrait motiver les gens a choisi la
martinique donc dans notre projet donc
nous commençons par ce retour empreint
semi marathon qui a déjà son succès
populaire et puis qui internationale
donc il n'y avait pas de raison que la
fédération n'y soit pas une nouvelle
yole à fort de france cela relance
encore plus la passion pour laguiole ben
oui on accueilli cette arrivée avec
bonheur surtout que mon au delà du
chiffre ça fait ça change nous passons
de 15 à ces ions
mais c'est surtout le patron qui l'a
conduit ces lots romas laurent mas qu'on
a connu avec son frère se lier aux
appétits qui ont une occasion à porter
le taux est aujourd'hui laurent s'impose
en patron et je pense que ça devrait
donner quelque chose je sais pas pendant
toute la saison
la saison a débuté quatre des vaux
réellement de cette saison mais que les
choses se déroulent dans la meilleure
des meilleures conditions possibles bon
et bien on tire sur tout ce que nous
attachons à faire depuis notre arrivée
et puis qu'on est au bout de ce
championnat un bon champion est très bon
champion comme on en a déjà eu
et puis ce qui laissera augurer un très
bon taux aujourd'hui les choses sont
sans clé les yoleurs les dossiers sont
prêts les patrons sont prêts et après
cette première pause on verra bien ce
que ça va donner au bout de saison la
fédération accompagné travail pour lier
le patrimoine de l'humanité toujours on
accompagne le site inauguré son sont
copines son comité de pilotage laguiole
n'est pas organisatrice maintenant
monsieur synovus a déposé son projet il
était aussi naturel que nous soyons à
ses côtés et donc on attend on attend et
on travaille façon tout ce que nous
faisons les compétitions que nous
organisons la vie associative que nous
essayons de contenir avec les présidents
bien que tout ça participe au succès de
laguiole et on espère que ça sera un
succès pour la martinique avant toute
chose si nous sommes aux produits de
l'unesco dédié question lors de la mini
transat on a vu les initiations laguiole
pour les navigateurs
c'est dans cette conception c'est qu'il
faut travailler ratisser large ah ben
oui comme je vous dis qu'on est revenu
dans revient dans grass est partie
touristique parce qu'on considère qu'
aujourd'hui chaque fois qu'un touriste
fait le choix de la destination
martinique
au delà de visiter nos beaux sites et de
faire des activités dans le département
il y à aussi dans ce programme là
laguiole en négociation qu'il faudra
qu'ils aient voilà donc c'est dimanche
que nous inscrivons tout ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui les associations de plus en
plus nous ont sollicités on sait qu lier
dans dans son système et un excellent
j'avais des moyens de cohésion ou des
entreprises pour des associations
donc c'est un outil à utiliser dans ce
sens